is wonderful to have it a movie that is
sort of based on the cutting technology
of the day or something where all the
artists who are trying to push that
envelope have a place to show their
wares
we sort of developed a look for the
character that kind of had elements of
David Bowie Ziggy Stardust
frank-n-furter and the emcee from
cabaret and in all that I'm sort of like
a circus show um enormous and it's we
wanted my character to look different to
all the other characters in the Tron
world so he's all completely white so I
had to keep it very very clean that was
the first thing I also had higher heels
I think than any other woman on the set
and it was incredibly it was incredibly
tight-fitting so I had to be kind of
harnessed into it every morning and then
and then I couldn't sit down all day so
we had these special things invented
like a stand with a bicycle seat on it
so that when you relaxed in between
takes and I use the word relaxed very
loosely you just kind of lean on this
bicycle seat and then just wait until
they called you to the second how you
look and it's very streamlined you know
and I think you wanted to be like second
skin but to create something like that
that's four layers because you have you
know a kind of course that type layer a
barrier electronic layer sued how do you
do that
like how do you make it that streamline
and and so it was it was an ever-growing
process we try this on that doesn't work
and the design suit designers customers
were the best of the best one of the one
of the reasons I I was drawn to this
second film it was an opportunity to
work on a
a modern-day myth you know myths help us
to navigate difficult spots in our in
our lives and we need modern day myths
to help us with things like technology
and how to deal with a darker side it's
very exciting and fun to think of all
these things we can do but we often
don't know what the ramifications are I
promised you that if I ever got any
information about your dad I'd tell you
first right to be able to come back all
these years later and be involved in
such a you know fantastic experience
especially since the technology has
advanced to such an extent now having
Joseph Kosinski behind me with his with
his his background in architecture and
you know just he's really sort of
sustained sort of he's just got this
vision that's incredible and I can't
wait for the rest of the world to see